welcome today we're going to show you
how to start keto
correctly and this is for beginners
what are we trying to do we're trying to
switch what your body
is running on as far as fuel-wise so we
want to switch from burning
sugar fuel to fat fuel there's this one
hormone called
insulin which is the key to determine
whether you're going to
burn fat or burn sugar so you want to
keep it
low to burn fat when it goes
higher your body will burn sugar
very simply lower your carbs
and eat less meals that's different
than lowering your calories now by
eating less meals
you are going to lower your calories but
that's not the goal you could actually
eat
larger meals just not as frequent
why is it a good idea to eat less
frequent meals
because every time you eat you trigger
insulin
every time you eat carbs you trigger
insulin so we're just trying to lower
this insulin the combination between
these two
are very very powerful so what are you
going to eat in a meal
well first thing you have to eat low
carb so you want to cut down all your
carbs that includes
sugar and i'm talking about honey agave
nectar
brown sugar white sugar date sugar
all sugar you can replace it
in various recipes with what's called
sugar alcohols
i put some links down below of examples
of that so you can learn about that but
there's
these sweet alternative sugar
sources that you can use so that means
that when you go
buy food you have to start reading the
labels and looking at the sugar content
you want it
as close to zero as possible you want to
avoid fruit
except for berries there's three berries
raspberries
strawberries and blackberries you can
have those in small amounts
but no other fruit especially apples
grains like wheat flour that they make
breads pasta cereal crackers biscuits
you want to avoid that
but guess what there's a substitute
there's a
people use almond flour to make all
sorts of things from
pizza crust to bread to you name it so
there's a lot of recipes that you can
use
as an alternative grain avoid starches
like potatoes
but guess what there's all these recipes
that you can make out of cauliflower
that is very similar to the starches not
identical
but you can make things that are very
close to tasting like mashed potatoes
you can even make a cauliflower crust
for your pizza
it's quite good now when i say cut out
all the carbs
there's an exception vegetables in fact
you want to consume
more vegetables at least seven cups
you know even more that could be salads
or other types of vegetables like bell
peppers
like cabbage like broccoli kale
brussels sprouts and at this level that
i'm teaching you you can even do carrots
and tomatoes
beets don't worry about that you can
have those and the last point about
vegetables is that
ideally if you eat them first it's going
to be a lot easier to consume
seven cups than after you have the
protein
and fat because this is going to fill
you up pretty fast so i always consume
the vegetable
first now you can consume it at the same
time
but just as a strategy to make sure you
get enough vegetables in your diet
i like to consume these first because
very few people consume
enough vegetables and one last point
vegetables provide two things they
provide food for your microbes that then
help your blood sugars
and help give you energy also they
provide a lot of nutrients like
potassium and magnesium and even vitamin
c because what are we trying to do we're
trying to do keto correctly and by
correctly i mean
healthily okay number two moderate
protein not massive amounts
like in the atkins diet but moderate
amounts that could be
depending on your size and your
metabolism and your age
between three and eight ounces maybe
you're 18 years old and you
work out hardcore you're gonna need
maybe more protein
so rather than have a little scale and
measure it just consume
protein the size of the palm of your
hand maybe a little bit more
a little less okay just to kind of keep
it really simple at this level
what type of protein different types of
meat fish
chicken seafood eggs cheese unless you
have an allergy
or any type of severe gut issue
nuts or nut butters
also make sure that you if you buy
peanut butter or whatever
you read the ingredients to make sure it
doesn't have added
sugar you don't want to add sugar to
any of these because sometimes when you
have like deli meats they have dextrose
in there or
extra sugar if you're having bacon they
have extra sugar added you
preferably keep the sugar away from your
protein
all right with the protein as far as the
order of when you eat it you just ate
your vegetable
your salad now you start with your
protein
the key with the protein is not to
consume lean protein or low fat protein
try to consume protein that has
more fat why because that's going to
help your insulin levels
when you consume protein that's very low
fat and lean as in like
powders especially like whey protein
powder
you majorly increase insulin
versus consuming fattier meat or fattier
fish or like brie cheese which is has
more
fat so that's a really key point about
protein all right the third thing is
that you're on a higher fat diet
now when we talk about higher fats
mainly we're talking about
the calories there's more than twice as
many
calories in fat than there is protein in
carbs
so based on calories it would be a
higher fat diet so i'm not going to say
anything more to confuse you on that
point
but realize that when you're consuming
the protein guess what you're consuming
a lot of the fat in your diet already
because protein
always comes with fat but
you may add some additional fats let's
say
some avocado butter to
cook your food in or let's say you melt
the butter on your vegetables
which is a good idea because the veggies
have certain fat soluble
natural chemicals in there that are good
for you even antioxidants
they're called phytonutrients and adding
oil
to your salad whether it's olive oil or
butter over your vegetables
will help you extract those nutrients
out of that meal
that's why it's good to combine these
things right here olives or olive oil is
very very good
coconut oil is actually also pretty good
and of course some of these are in the
fat category like
nuts for example or half fat and half
protein
a little bit of carb cheese is protein
and fat
eggs are protein and fat so a lot of
these are fat too
so both of these are kind of a
combination
but if you're starting keto a lot of
times people add
maybe some nuts or cheese after the meal
to be more satisfied so that's something
that they do
and so that's why i said eat this third
but of course
it could be within the meal now there's
certain fats you definitely want to
avoid
soy oil corn oil canola oil cottonseed
oil
even the safflower oil the sunflower oil
i would be careful about consuming too
much of those
these are gmo they have chemicals in
them but the problem is they're highly
inflammatory
even though it's a fat it's the wrong
type of fat that you want in your body
and you probably see these in salad
dressings and
many different products like mayonnaise
in there so you're going to have to kind
of start reading labels
and really get picky on certain things
that you're going to be
buying so we talked about generally what
to eat
but we also want to talk about eating
less meals right less frequent meals
we're going to do intermittent fasting
we're going to combine both of these
together
to really take that insulin and bring it
down to our normal level so
here's the rule of thumb don't eat
unless you are hungry
now let me define hungry because
sometimes you might
get a little bit of hunger but you still
feel strong
uh you still feel fine your mood is good
we'll try to push through that okay
there's also a difference between hunger
and also like a habit people have like a
habit of eating
all the time even when they're not
hungry because they feel that
they're not as full as maybe they should
be
so you don't have to be full all the
time
we're talking about hungry and a true
hunger is like wow
i feel like i really need to eat i feel
a little bit weaker
i feel a little shaky i'm starting to
notice i'm a little bit more irritable
okay
that is what we're talking about not
some little
temporary hunger number two
ideally you want to skip the breakfast
you can do this on a
gradual level where you keep pushing
your breakfast later and later and later
or just cut it right out and just skip
breakfast instead have your coffee
with a little butter in it a tablespoon
of butter
and or mct oil which
will help you greatly in making
ketones which is very therapeutic to
your brain and it'll satisfy you
so as you're trying to transition into
the state of ketosis which you're
burning fat
because ketones are a byproduct of
burning fat
if you add mct oil
that will give you ketones right away
and it'll make the transition a little
more comfortable especially with your
cognitive function
so this is a good idea and if you did
this coffee with this
these two fats it's going to be very
easy to skip
breakfast also i want to note that about
8 am in the morning
is when you have this hormonal shift
with cortisol might go up
and you may find a temporary about a
half hour
kind of a a sense like i i'm ready to
eat something
it's the cortisol it's a hormonal shift
and it can
increase your appetite just ignore that
and
push through that okay so we're skipping
our breakfast at this point number three
very importantly do not snack through
the day
that little snack even though it's low
amount of calories
will make you hungry eating
stimulates hunger especially if it's in
the form of a snack
so just cut out all snacking it's very
very
important if you get the temptation the
snack
just realize that you didn't consume
enough fat
at the last meal so the next meal add
more fat to the diet
so you can go easily from one meal to
the next
so it's important to add more fat to go
longer
there's a lot of details to fill in the
blank but typically you can drink
water tea coffee anything without sugar
you can take your vitamins it's not
going to be a problem
and again there's a lot of details that
i'm not covering but i'm just giving you
the basics
so let's say your first meal is at noon
okay you eat your meal
don't really worry at this point about
calories because we're not trying to
reduce calories all we're trying to do
is have that first meal
make sure it fits what i said in the
last slide and then the second meal at
six so that gives you a six hour eating
window
and 18-hour fast okay if you don't snack
which is huge this is going to allow you
to
see a lot of benefits with this program
so that is the summary of how to do
keto correctly before you go if you have
a question about a product
or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin
keto or you're on keto and you need a
debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help